dea
俺は巨大なサメだ体調は nm 派は三千本
好物は魚そんな立派なサメである俺は今名古屋にあるカフェに来たところだ
どうやって国に来たのかわからんがひどく腹が減っているのか
俺は糧に入ったレジの向こうに立ち髪をポニーテールにしている店員がギョッとした
アナメイト
思わるサメがこの店を訪れたの初めてかもしれない
俺はレジへと体をぎこちなくばたつかせ始めた
体の目がさらに大きくなっていきゲーム手が震えだした食べられるんじゃないかとかは
がっているのは俺はレジにつき注文した水を5杯ください
水ですか食べ物よりもサメにとっては水のほうがた
アジだ水水だけですか
俺はレジのつ形に置いてあった看板に視線を移した
そして一番最初に目に入ったものを注文してみた
ホットコーヒーホットコーヒーですと恐怖の生花店は添えて一瞬言葉に詰まった人間は
恐怖にとらわれている時にさらにおいしい
そうに見える4とコーヒーですとドーナツが無料で付きますがいいかがですか
どうなって
そんな言葉を口にしたのは生まれて初めてだった
こちらですつやつやしたものがいっぱい載っている丸い塊
なぜかん真ん中に大きなを長いている
よくわからないものが坂野申し訳ございませんこちらはドーナツ家庭なので次つ食べ
られるかわからない
しかしで同じ知識がゼロだおすすめを最近彼女はそう言って再び言葉に詰まった最近
こちらが人気です甘くてとてもおいしいです
あまーいってどういう事だろうと思いながら
ノーズがさせたものに目を向ける墓のによりはるかに穴が大きかった
ドーナツは穴が大きいほど美味しいんだろうか
これ俺お体のおすすめを無視して最もあの小さいものを一れるさせた
1週間いいず何も食べていない味なんか気にしてる場合じゃなかった
かしこまりました少々お待ちください激しく手を震わせながら店員はドーナツとホット
コーヒーと5杯の水をトレイに乗せ
コントの向こうから差し出してきた350になります
と言われた瞬間にコネを持っていないことに気づいた表情が微妙に変わったのか体も
それが分かったようだ
俺た長に3秒見つめ合った
ありがとうございました俺も水を1杯ずつ顔に跳ねかけたそしてホットコーヒーと
ドーナツの乗っているとれい尾鰭に乗せ
席へと体をパターつかせたもったいないことにほとんどホットコーヒーが床にこぼれて
しまった席に着くちょっと前に店のドアから3人の若い女性が入ってきた彼女たちは
私たちよりキレイな人はこんなドーナツ
カフェにいないよねーと白い歯を見せて大きく笑いながらゆっくりと店の中を見回した
皆足が辛くて髪がツヤツヤしている
そして自惚れているため彼女たちは巨大なサメの存在に気づかないこれは笑みをこぼし
た
そして半分空気であるドーナツを食べてから彼女たちの方に滑り始めた
一番カロリーの低い
移動夏てどれもっともか3月予定をしている女がポニーテールの店員に大きな声そうを
聞いた
こちらです点はソイて先ほどおりに進めたあの大きいドーナツを刺した人間はやはり
カロリーが低いほど喜ぶようだ
しかサメも違う俺はさらに彼女たちの部に近づいていた
どうしようさっき野菜ジュース飲んでもんねえみちゃんまだ全然細いじゃん食べちゃ
ねぇもう45キロ超えちゃうよまじ
それやばくねこれはさらに近づいておいたコーヒーだけにしようかな
はるちゃん何にする私さっきされる食べちゃってから水でいいよ水その言葉を
聞いた瞬間氷の食欲が激増したてかやめようか
ここ美味しいものなさそうだしえみちゃんをそう言ってドアの方を振り返った
そこに俺が入ったなんかよあるゆみちゃんをそう言っていろいろした面持ちで前を揚げ
たドーナツ一つよりもカロリーの低そうな彼女の脚に
俺は何も言わずかみついたポニーテールの店員は小さく笑ってまたグラスに水を注ぎ
始めた
tan
me
rar